the movie you're promoting happily yes
uh
let's talk about it again uh we have a
clip but before we do that
i understand that you have found ways to
be naked in this movie as well to show
off your findings i have
thank you for saying that yes why play
the husband
to the uh a lovely amazing actor named
carrie beshea
she's one of the best actors i've ever
worked with i hope you have her on the
show soon
i'm sure she's dying to be on this
program no
we play a married couple that have sex
three times a day and we've been married
14 years
ah and you're doing science fiction now
oh
come on uh so we have a clip here from
hapley uh
set up the clip for us won't you joel uh
yes so this clip i'm gonna set up
okay is i'm i i'm not sure i think you
guys are about to go
you and your lovely wife are about to go
on a weekend getaway right
okay [ __ ]
because they usually uh yeah we're about
to go we are trying
oh that's right you usually care about a
show you're on no
no it's look i know i
i've i have i have no um i
wow i had some of this whiskey and no
this clip
if i i'm not gonna remember it right
someone has died and we're not sure if
we're
we're pretty sure we're responsible so
we're trying to
figure out how to behave as if you've
just killed someone without
seeming out of place so got it we are
yes is that correct no no god damn it
no you just set up the wrong clip let's
throw to this clip
uh from happily and um all of this
america has to
america has to know and they will know
about you this is
airing in america
[Laughter]
that's so cool oh man
we think let's take a look at this clip
from happily somebody
is going to come looking for him we
don't know that
yes we do and i don't want to be here
when that happens
where do you want to go i don't know
anywhere i mean literally
anywhere oh my gosh
[Music]
hi karen i just wanted to call and
apologize
i think we may have been a little harsh
last night thanks
look if you guys are still interested in
getting out of town for the weekend we'd
love for you to come on the couple's
trip
that sounds great we would love to
perfect i'll text you the address in the
code for the front gate
amazing see you tomorrow
bye
is this a good idea you said anywhere
okay now i can explain the clip
let's hear this has never been done we
show the clip and then you explain it
uh yeah because our friends because we
have so much sex
uh they hate us and they dis-invite us
to the weekend
away can you put this in the beginning
of the clip i'd rather you didn't
they they reinvite us because they feel
bad as you saw
that was the amazing natalie z and uh on
the phone but uh
that that's that's when we decided to go
away for the weekend with our friends
and
then everybody dies okay now you just
gave that away
did he have his shirt on i couldn't see
the clip what they did is they digitally
added a shirt afterwards oh okay
because they realize that he's shirtless
in every single
scene yeah it's it's an army green shirt
with like an army green sweater on top
[Laughter]
um all right we're going to wrap this up
why well
you've alienated my audience and i think
your audience is paper
i know and they're not having it they're
you have your uh sona's gone into labor
yeah you're you're the writer mike is
that him
uh that's matt matt mike yeah he's
like mike was the other guy yeah mike is
the other writer
i have two writers uh yes as depicted on
larry sanders you only need two
um uh when was the last time you watched
larry sanders
please another unproductive cul-de-sac
and i won't go down
i keep trying to drive this car to the
airport and you keep
saying hey there's an alley let's go
down there at 90 miles an hour let's see
what's there
i mean you might get something let's let
it go
the important thing to get out there one
thing first of all i want to say happily
is available this friday in theaters
digital
and video on demand and i also want to
mention
that when you drove you were constantly
wheeling and dealing because you were a
wheeler dealer
and true story he drives up in a very
nice car and rolls down the window and
we haven't seen
each other in a year and we've been
texting and talking and sexting and
whatever and the his his
window comes down and and and i said oh
nice car and he said do you want to buy
it
and you weren't kidding you tried to
sell me your car
in the alley outside this theater
because you found another car you like
and you tried to sell it to me
i think it's a great car for you it's
not a great car
no no no you i know that you're a tall
man but it's a sports car it's
two-seater but it fits
right no one wastes time like you uh
you're a good man it's a lot of fun
thank you thank you very much